[Musique]
bonsoir un rebondissements dramatiques
dans un fait divers
déjà particulièrement sordide une bombe
dans un cinéma où se donnaient un
festival international du film juifs des
réfugiés basques abattus sur le
territoire français par les commandos du
gal un jeune arabe tué à miramas à une
autre ratonnades à menton avec là encore
mort d'homme le sang monsieur le
ministre le son a beaucoup coulé en
france ces trois derniers jours
alors les questions ce soir ne manquent
pas sur cette actualité violente et
disparates que les français ont un peu
tendance à amalgamer alors questions sur
la façon dont la justice est rendue dans
ce pays
question sur le racisme et sur les
responsabilités de ceux qui répandent la
haine par leur discours questions sur la
place grandissante que prend aujourd'hui
dans le débat politique
tout ce qui touche à la justice à la
sécurité et au châtiment
et puis question plus personnelle aussi
monsieur badinter
quel effet cela vous fait-il à vous
l'avocat le plus célèbre de france
devenue aujourd'hui ministre de la
justice de déchaîner les passions et de
polariser sur votre nom tous les procès
qui sont faits à la machine judiciaire
française les prisons de france n'ont
jamais été aussi pleine que sous votre
règne
et pourtant et pourtant pour les
français vous êtes celui qui passe son
temps à libérer les voyous monsieur le
ministre vous allez avoir une heure pour
plaider votre cause une heure pour
expliquer votre politique et commenter
vos résultats en répondant à philippe
tesson directeur du quotidien de paris
et aux trois journalistes qui forment
l'équipe permanente de l'heure de vérité
albert du roy alain duhamel et
jean-louis le scène qui va vous poser
tout de suite la première question au
nom des téléspectateurs jean-louis le
cns vp robert badinter bonsoir beaucoup
de questions pour vous ce soir ici svp
des questions qui s'adresse au ministre
de la justice bien sûr mais aussi aux
professeurs de droit et à l'homme au
ministre d'abord avec actualité oblige
un nombre impressionnant
d'interrogations sur la sphère du petit
grégory pourquoi cette affaire traite l
otan comptez-vous prendre des mesures
pour accélérer les choses
ne regrettez vous pas aujourd'hui de ne
pas avoir reçu les parents est en marche
que pensez-vous du pouvoir démentiel des
juges d'instruction pourquoi confie-t-on
d instruction aussi délicate à de jeunes
juges en début de carrière
quatre questions parmi beaucoup beaucoup
d'autres oui ça fait beaucoup de
questions et je pense qu'on y reviendra
si vous vous répondre peut-être
brièvement d'abord je suis sûr qu'on y
reviendra ensuite dans le cours de
l'émission
en ce qui concerne les questions posées
jeu ça bref la lenteur il s'agit d'une
affaire criminelle particulièrement
difficile
un drame humain qui touche profondément
j'aimerais qu'on se souvienne de temps
d'affaires judiciaires importantes comme
ça dans des milieux assez fermé et je
pense en particulier à la sphère
dominique si ce n'est pas facile vous
savez la recherche de la vérité mais
cela demande du temps beaucoup de soin
et je dirais aussi beaucoup de sérénité
qui fait défaut à l'heure actuelle
malheureusement recevoir les parents
j'ai une règle absolue depuis que je
suis garde des sceaux je ne se soit
jamais je dis bien jamais aucun avocat
d'aucune partie dans aucune affaire pas
plus qu'aucune des parties en ce qui
concerne le pouvoir qu'on a qualifié
tout à fait à tort de démentiel les
juges d'instruction n'ont les juges
d'instruction ce sont des magistrats du
siège
ils ont en effet un grand pouvoir mais
vous savez il ya beaucoup d'autres
jugent qu'ils entendront pouvoir et
qu'ils exercent de façon solitaire
je pense en particulier juge des enfants
ne parle pas beaucoup mais ils ont
toutes les femmes et tous les hommes de
justice le savent
un considérable ouvreur les juges
d'application des peines dont on parle
encore moins ils peuvent décider de la
libération conditionnelle décidée les
permissions de sortie
le juge aux affaires matrimoniales qui
lui aussi décident de la garde d'enfant
avec tout ce que cela signifie comme
épreuve humaine partout de grandes
responsabilités alors simplement le juge
d'instruction eh bien je dirais que il
est là il est présent il est mêlé au
crime il
au fait divers on parle plus de lui je
le dis très clairement et dès le départ
je suis excédé et du procès qu'on fait
la justice française et son injustice et
du procès conduites actuellement à
l'encontre des juges d'instruction sais
pas je tiens quand même à rappeler que
ce sont des hommes qui exercent une
fonction difficile que ce sont des
hommes qui ont des nuits difficiles avec
de grands problèmes de conscience que ce
sont des hommes ils oublient parfois
qu'ils payent de leur vie leur courage
dans l'exercice de leurs fonctions je
veux rappeler aux téléspectateurs que
les magistrats mort dans les dernières
années ce sont deux juges d'instruction
c'est le juge renaud et le juge michel
et les mêmes journaux que je vois
aujourd'hui s'impatienter à propos de
tel juge d'instruction je rappelle
combien ils font à juste titre cette
fois là les langes de telle ou telle de
ce qu'ils appellent des petits juges
alors justice aussi pour les juges
d'instruction donc musée le violoniste
alors alain duhamel pour un quart
d'heure face avoue alain duhamel
pour sa part se garde des sceaux bonsoir
alors naturellement je vais commencer
par l' affaire grégory parce que je
crois que c'est à ce sujet que ce soir
beaucoup de français se posent beaucoup
de questions d'abord pour que les choses
soient bien claires
est ce que dans cette affaire de près ou
de loin vous même est intervenue est ce
que vous avez donné des instructions au
parquet par exemple la fin est ce que
robert badinter a eu d'une manière ou
d'une autre à intervenir en quoi que ce
soit je suis vieux mail pour que les
choses soient plus claires encore et
vous savez très bien qu'il va être ma
réponse car vous la connaissez par
avance le garde des sceaux ne peut pas
en public
évoquer quelques affaires que ce soir il
ya quelqu'un qui doit respecter le
secret de l'instruction va dire
qu'aujourd'hui il est bien mal en point
ces liens de dessins de parler d'une
affaire en cours d'instruction
et pour que ce soit plus clair encore
vous le savez exclut aussi de commenter
quelques décisions de justice que ce
soit encore dans les décisions de
justice il y a les militants attention
aux joueurs comme il pourra y avoir d
ordonnance de non lieu
ça c'est le respect de l'indépendance
des magistrats loi absolue que je ne
déroge pas d'un vrai que vous décevoir
alors je vais quand même essayer un
certain nombre de choses que j'aimerais
bien voir
d'abord parce que vous avez le sentiment
que dans cette affaire c'est à dire dans
les lenteurs surtout les hésitations
voire les contradictions auxquelles on a
le sentiment d'assister puis dans le
meurtre d'un inculpé remis en liberté
est ce que vous y voyez vous un échec de
la justice
bien que vous essayez par la bande de me
ramener là où je veux pas à les gérer
comme journaliste comme tout journaliste
j'ai c'est que vous posez des questions
que les français se posent rien large et
ce au nom c'est pas le bon c'est pas le
bon interlocuteur mais simplement encore
une fois une référence vous rappeler les
difficultés de la sphère 2010 pour le
voir aller tout seul toutes les affaires
ne sont pas faciles
il en est de très difficile et dans lé
monde très clos quand il s'agit de g
comme cela c'est encore plus difficile
et encore une fois je crois que ce n'est
pas la passion qui règne autour de la
sphère qui favorise la tâche de la
justice comme dans un premier temps
c'est la gendarmerie qui est chargé de
procéder à des recherches m selon les
officiers de police
mais non mais moi je ne critique pas et
que dans un second temps c'est la police
judiciaire est-ce qu'il y en a pas
certains qui sont démenties et d'autres
qui ne le sont pas je la veux dire qu'on
passe d'un corps de la police judiciaire
à un autre corps de la police judiciaire
si cela est mieux pour la justice tant
de bien
quand on assiste comme c'est le cas
cette fois-ci vraiment de façon aussi
spectaculaire que possible à une
instruction qui est un peu et là ça va
vous permettre de me répondre en
élargissant le propos qui est un peu une
instruction passoire c'est à dire qu'on
a l'impression que tout le monde est au
courant de demi vérités sans arrêt ses
demi vérités on l'a vu et on le constate
alimentent des rumeurs et ces rumeurs
quelquefois on l'a constaté sont des
rumeurs qui tue on l'a vu et on l'a vu
cette fois ci à julien mages interrompt
tout de suite oui vous pouvez pas aller
à une simplification de cette nature ce
n'est pas bien mais on dirait que ce
n'est pas juste
yamna parlez pas de ya pas de rumeurs tu
n'y a pas de rumeurs pas savoir quelle
est la cause d'un acte criminel
je viens d'avoir plusieurs il peut y en
avoir une seule mais ne prononce pas ce
genre de jeune fille alors est ce que le
problème de du secret de l'instruction
1 est ce que le problème du secret
d'instruction ne risque pas en étant
traités de façon ouverte un jeu c'est de
prendre un mot neutre risquait d'
alimenter des rumeurs lesquels risquent
à leur tour d'influencé oui là où je
vous livrais alors toute ma pensée c'est
que je crois qu'il soit bon pour la
justice que la longueur maintenant le
journée l'entendent ainsi les avocats
les parties les témoins pour l
impression que les confrontations ont
lieu maintenant dans les salles de
rédaction avec un micro toujours tendue
je repars je crois encore une fois que
la justice ait besoin de plus de calme
je sais bien que les juges voulaient en
cure heures devraient s'abstenir de
sommeil qu'elle veut dire que je sens
gerald secret de l'instruction qui se
taisent concerne le mans c'est bien en
effet les juges et procureurs et les
avocats parlent au combien restent à
faire valoir les moyens qui peuvent
servir la cause de ce qu'il défend
c'est normal ce sont quand même des vues
qui sont par définition orienter les
télés marty qui fondent normale du
concours pas la procédure bien entendu
mais eux les magistrats se taisent et je
dis quelquefois de secret de
l'instruction il ne joue plus que contre
les magistrats alors le vrai problème
c'est comment faire en sorte que la
justice puisse fonctionner et que
l'information puisse se faire je pense
que on est en présence d'une difficulté
actuellement
qui tient peut-être à l'évolution même
des techniques et faits divers ont
toujours passionné je voudrais le jour
du 18ème siècle on retrouve toujours les
crimes l'origine
enfin c'est la presse écrite et c'est la
presse qui est généralement plus lente à
se mettre en marche au 19e siècle
aujourd'hui toujours à cause des moyens
de communication aujourd'hui on est
passé de la presse écrite à la presse
audiovisuelle et alassane est plus
visuel bref qu'est ce que tu m'apportes
aujourd'hui dans la sphère coco c'est
qu'est-ce qui a depuis tout à l'heure
alors inévitablement se rend bien compte
j'aurais agir sur l'instant l'avocat
pense inévitablement à la réaction qui
peut y avoir sur la conscience
collective de tel ou tel évènement il se
dépêche de prendre position tant de
faire publiquement
enfin on peut admettre cette pression
cette réponse
même chose en ce qui concerne les
parties alors tout cela ils étaient 16
même chose pour les témoins dans ce cas
là vous recommander alors moi je pense
pour ma part d'abord que il faut une
meilleure prise de conscience
vous êtes peut-être marqué que ce qui
est exceptionnel il y a quinze jours de
cela le procureur général a diffusé un
communiqué dans lequel il ne disait rien
d'autre que ceux ci
sommes un tournant d'une affaire très
difficile avec des résonances humaine
très profonde
je demande instamment à toute la presse
de concilier la liberté de l'information
qui doit être absolument respectée avec
toutes les réserves possibles
à propos des personnes dans des
circonstances comme cela on va dire
qu'il était bien si bien suivi son
article en pratique
mais en pratique je crois que il faut
que la justice puisque nous sommes dans
une société de communication
je dirais maîtrise mieux à son tour la
communication alors comment d'abord je
demanderai à présent au procureur de la
république de publier plus souvent et je
dirais ne peut-être dans un style moins
juridique moins abstrait plus accessible
des communiqués mais à chaque fois qu'il
faudra donner une précision qu'on sache
que ceci est le point de vue du parcours
c'est à dire on dira plus directement en
dire plus directement sous forme de
communiqué et à l'extra eh bien on
pourra concevoir en présence d'une
contre-vérités flagrantes par rapport un
élément décisif d'un dossier la légende
où la rumeur commence à se répandre
par exemple on cite une partie d'une
expertisé par le reste est bien dans ce
cas là on peut envisager que le juge
d'instruction en accord ou bien le
président de la juridiction en a
convaincu le président la jolie sion à
la demande du juge d'instruction
en tout cas qu un communiqué émanant du
siège aussi au rayon pour combat les
rumeurs de façon à ce que les choses
soient précises et je dirais précisé
parce qu'ils n'ont aucun intérêt dans la
sphère alors aussi je crois
voyez-vous monsieur duhamel et volera
léo et je vais dans quinze jours l'école
nationale de la magistrature j'y vais
tous les ans quelques fois deux fois par
an une nouvelle promotion d'auditeurs eh
bien il faut maintenant que les
magistrats se familiarise mieux avec la
communication et je crois que dans les
grandes juridictions et il y aura un
magistrat qui je n'ai pas sera chargé de
la communication
mais qui y veillera bref comme aux
armées
dans la nuit il ya un officier chargé
des relations extérieures objectifs sont
plus renom pas charger légèrement comme
ça de relations publiques non chargé de
veiller à ce que la communication se
fasse mais c'est l'intérêt chez nous ne
pouvons pas avoir une justice qui soit
hors de la cité
il faut qu'elle puisse s'exprimer mais
elle doit faire attention sur un point
précis vous ne me parlerait pas de la
faire je sais sur un point précis on a
vu la place dans l'opinion que prenait
maintenant des expertises le cas échéant
présenter partiellement
et puis on a vu aussi des renversements
des expertises
est ce que ça ne pose pas un énorme
problème justement d'information est ce
que quand on a le dos ça donne le
sentiment que c'est quelqu'un qui est
plutôt à priori un futur inculpés est
perçu que c'est quelqu'un d'autre et sur
des bases en partie scientifique
oui là aussi de rappel le premier la vie
judiciaire l'histoire judiciaire
les plaines de problèmes d' expertise
débouche sur telle conclusion ensuite de
l'avant tel autre l' affaire dreyfus
marie besnard pour ne citer que les plus
illustres donc les magistrats évidemment
soit l'avis des experts - les y font
attention est ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'il ne faut pas se précipiter pour
qu'il ya une déduction ou une conclusion
définitive à partir d'une expertise et
puis alors ce que je voudrais rappeler
monsieur duhamel c'est qu'il faut que
nos concitoyens que les français sachent
bien que l'inculpation ce n'est pas la
condamnation que l'inculpation en france
cela veut dire qu'il se trouve dans le
dossier des charges contre un
justiciable mais seulement des charges
qu'il est encore présumé innocent et
l'inculpation je lisais toujours à mes
étudiants elle a une fonction qu'on
oublie trop souvent c'est qu'elle
déclenche des droits de la défense
si on accule ça n'est pas seulement
parce que on désigne du doigt c'est pas
ça l'inculpé c'est parce que la loi veut
le droit veut que l'inculpé puissent
grâce à son avocat avoir connaissance du
dossier et préparer sa défense parce
qu'on est en présence
charge d'envoyer cette espèce de
confusion dans les esprits on accule
c'est le coupable non c'est un homme
contre lequel il ya des charges les
charges face aux combats je dirais que
la défense est là pour ça et à partir de
ce moment là eh bien on assiste un
deuxième temps de l'instruction
mais cette conclusion immédiat il est
inculpé il est coupable et alors ensuite
on dit comment il a été inculpé mais
quoi il peut y avoir un non-lieu donc
c'était une erreur judiciaire non c'est
la démarche de la loi alors sûr c'est
sur cet aspect des choses j'ai encore
deux dernières questions à vous poser
puis ensuite on passera à autre chose la
première en dehors de ce à quoi vous
êtes en train de changer vous nous avez
expliqué à propos des magistrats et de
la communication éventuelle dans
certains caractères à vous qui avez une
expérience étendue de ce genre
d'affaires difficile
est ce que vous connaissez des moyens
pour empêcher des rumeurs de détruire
ensuite l'existence quelquefois pas
l'existence forcément physiques mais
simplement l'honorabilité donc la vie de
quelqu'un qui a été mis en cause à tort
et le cas échéant de façon approximative
ce que vous voyez une parade et ça j'en
vois deux peut-être pas suffisantes les
gens voient de la première monsieur
duhamel s'est opposé à la rumeur la
précision qui tue la rumeur et c'est le
communiqué que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
et puis la deuxième beaucoup plus
difficile c'est une sorte de l'exigence
d'exigence à l'égard de soi même et des
autres qui fait que si on rapporte telle
rumeur est bien là credic pas parce
qu'elle paraît sensationnel ou 9
on attend dans les écoles de journalisme
aux états unis et en france aussi je
crois on dit rien ne vaut si cela n'a
pas été vérifiées à plusieurs sources
cette démarche prudente gagnerait ne pas
être oublié la sortie de l'école souvent
alors la dernière question que je
voulais vous poser sur ce sujet est ce
qu'au fond quand on voit l'ensemble de
l'oeuvre que
vous avez ébauché ou accomplis comme on
veut depuis que vous êtes là
et puis que on est brusquement projeté
dans une affaire de ce genre où on a un
sentiment que derrière une pellicule de
civilisation il ya tellement de haine de
violence de jalousie qui viennent à nu
comme ça est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas en train de
nous préparer une justice du 21e siècle
pour une mentalité du 19e on peut être
être antérieure ou 19e
oui mais c'est parce que je voulais le
gentil le vieil homme
non on ne peut pas ne pas avoir la
justice de son temps et dit monsieur
duhamel l'oeuvre que j'ai ébauché ou
accompli disons que j'ai entreprise il
ya beaucoup de choses qui ont été faites
mais il ya beaucoup de choses encore à
faire mais c'est vrai c'est vrai que au
niveau des mentalités
le travail est constant est ce que des
progrès ont été réalisés suffisamment
crois qu'il y en a eu
je crois que quand la comme ça une
explosion qui est lié à un drame
judiciaire
le vieil homme revient facilement au
galop
alors là monsieur duhamel et puis j'ai
une réponse judiciaire c'est toute la
société qui peut s'interroger mais moi
qui en charge les justices je dis très
clairement
assez assez retour à la sérénité retour
la confiance dans la justice
le cal ça se la pète as commandes seul
avec la hollande si cela ne se commande
pas et vous savez c'est cette demande
que je fais à cet instant que la justice
soit laissée à elle même
quelle façon 9 alors je voudrais
commencer on a un autre thème qui
d'ailleurs est tout à fait liés parce
que à ce que vous venez de dire quand on
voit l'ensemble des attentats qui ont eu
lieu ces derniers jours
attentat antisémite attentats anti
arabes et anti musulmans
attentat anti basque et c est ce que
vous avez le sentiment
sincèrement je veux dire sans en
rajouter ce que vous avez le sentiment
qu'il ya en france en ce moment une
brusque accentuation du racisme ou pas
l'absolution je lui amène à que je me
passionne juste pas de nature en
rajouter comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure
alors je vous reste jusqu'au parlement
donc c'est symbolique et une volonté de
série n 2 p de part et d'autre je
voulais mon sentiment
il y à des attentats du type de ceux qui
viennent d'être commis là dans cette
salle de cinéma
difficile de dire si on est en présence
d'une action de terrorisme international
dans ce cas là quand même une forme de
racisme je veux dire c'est le cas ou si
en effet cette jihad
c'est sous l'antisionisme tc dijon c'est
du racisme importés oui ce
l'antisionisme ce que ça veut dire à cet
instant là parce que il y à des
israéliens en opération au liban alors
on doit tuer des juifs assis dans une
salle de cinéma à paris donc c'est
vraiment ici l'antisémitisme et qui est
camouflé sous le drapeau de
l'antisionisme mais c'est un acte de
terrorisme international
ça n'a rien à voir avec le racisme à
l'intérieur du pays par contre tout le
reste tout le reste je veux dire ce à
quoi on a assisté les maghrébins tu es
ici un autre là ces violences
et puis une multitude d'incidents
quotidien moi je vois ce que les parcs m
signale le racisme ordinaire depuis le
racisme de violence cela je crois
je crains monsieur duhamel qui ne soit
en train de monter dans le pays alors il
y avait si j'ose dire les conditions
objectives qui facilite les explosions
de racisme
il y avait la crise il y avait la
sécurité il y avait l'immigration y
avait tout ce qu'on veut bon bin
brusquement on a le sentiment depuis
quelques mois c'est quelque chose qui
s'accélère je pense que ce que vous
venez de dire correspond aux sentiments
commencent pourquoi est-ce que ça
cristallise plus brusquement maintenant
pourquoi est ce qu'il ya un certain
nombre de gens qui brusquement passe un
seuil qui est disons de l'exaspération
des parts ou de la fureur ou de la haine
et puis qui brusquement devient un acte
de violence qu'est ce qui fait que c'est
en ce moment tu as passe là-haut sing me
faut être prudent cependant je crois
d'abord que à part les causes
économiques que vous avez évoquées c'est
très important
le rapport se j'en suis convaincu
chômage action contre les immigrés c'est
certain mais à part les causes
économiques et autres choses parce que
c'est une montée et un moment donné on
assiste à l'explosion mais ça se prépare
le on voit d'abord à fleuret mais il ya
des seuils
ils voient bien seul quand on franchit
ce seuil mais avant il ya le longue
ovation bien je crois que pendant des
décennies on a vécu sur l'interdît
absolue qui résultat de la guerre le
racisme
c'était le nazisme le nazisme c'étaient
les mille juifs qu'on a envoyé à
auschwitz
parce qu'ils étaient juifs dont il y
avait une liaison
dans la conscience dans la conscience de
tous les européens des français aussi
entre racisme et nazisme et qui
faisaient que ce n'était pas possible
c'était barret et puis et vers les
années ont passé et c'est dur en même
temps il y avait en même temps des
formes de racisme dans les guerres
coloniales en même temps à la même
époque secte et c'est vrai ça n'est pas
vrai de la même façon selon ce que cela
se passe c'est cruel ce que je vais dire
mais ailleurs et qui si c'était là il
n'empêche les gens qui ont eu lieu à
paris contre ce racisme là et que je me
souviens
très bien des temps si difficiles ou et
apple avec les amis du comité audin on
luttait façon forcené pour que la vérité
sur ça je vais parler des arabes ont
jeté leurs armes
c'est exact c'est exact mais il y avait
d'abord le fait que son propre racisme
je parle de communauté nationale elle
n'aime pas le voir deuxièmement que ça
restait des actes individuels y avait
quand même cette barrière formidable
puis le temps a passé et puis d'une
nouvelle génération sont venus et il ya
aussi ce qui s'est passé c'est à dire le
fait que l'on a assisté dans tant de
meetings dans ton discours à une espèce
de réapparition au je ne dis pas de
l'appel au racisme et savez quand même
il y avait des connotations d
utilisation d utilisation pourquoi que
deux patients est situé à ce moment là
tout devient possible
quand on se réunit pour les très
nombreux quelques lattes le mépris pour
celui qui est l'autre la ra ble bougnoux
ce que vous voudrez il ya les rires
complices la censure sont et le racisme
apparaît alors la voie dernière question
j'aurais voulu continuer l'instant
justin sanctions reste très importante
et on là vous voyez je crois que
l'essentiel pas dans les lois nous nous
avons encore amélioré les lois vous le
savez les associations peuvent
maintenant se constituer partie civile
dans ces cas là d'un bon les parquets
sont vigilants les réquisitions sont
très fermes la justice fait ce qu'elle
doit
non au niveau est conscient je veux dire
la prise de conscience du racisme eh
bien elle est tout à fait essentiel au
niveau de la jeune génération
et quand il y à des actions comme celle
bien été conduite et le badge des rats
touche pas à mon pote
alors certains disent mais ce que
récupération non parce que ça montre de
la jeunesse elle même et le racisme
on ne peut le combattre que dans les
coeurs et tour est un des coeurs et bien
il faut que ces jeunes gens et le
sentiment d directement impliqué alors
c'est si vous voulez par rapport à ce
que je considère
si détestable détestable parce que le
racisme ça touche l'âme d'un pays
eh bien ces réactions là elle me donne
de l'espérance mais quand quand vous
quand vous dites que c'est ma dernière
question quand vous dites ça et quand
vous et vos amis fait ça est ce que au
fond vous nous attaquez pas à
l'idéologie raciste aux manifestations
d' idéologie raciste et pas aux racines
matériel du racisme voulait dire que le
combat reste très simplement
intellectuelle non j'ai passé je me
dirige et j'essayais de ne pas
caricaturer ce que vous disiez ça n'est
pas du tout ça parce que je veux dire ce
que je veux dire c'est que on peut on
peut et sans doute on doit enfin
sûrement même attaqué les manifestations
extérieures les manifestations affective
gourmet en dessous il ya eu des racines
qu'il faut que le racisme ne peut
exister mais j'ai eu m
la lutte contre le racisme ça ne se
divise pas c'est comme la liberté la
lutte contre le racisme monsieur duhamel
on l'amène à tout moment toute sa vie et
de toutes les façons alors vous n'avez
pas tort il y à la lutte par les idées
et aussi la lutte dans les faits il ya
aussi la lutte quotidienne
oui vous allez à l'urbanisation s'il y
avait bien sûr qu'ils sont bien sûr
et quand je disais la lutte quotidienne
je veux dire j'en reviens à ce rapport
de l'homme à l'homme le touche pas à mon
pote ne pas supporter que devant soi on
m'insulte ne pas supporter qu'on se
laisse aller à des violences ne pas
supporter non plus qu'il y ait cette
discrimination quotidienne
et puis alors en effet mais ça ce sont
les prendre les vôtres c'est lebron de
l'urbanisme qui est née c'est une autre
réflexion en amont ce que je voudrais
bien a ajouté c'est une totale en
amoureuse que vous connaissez un peuple
non raciste
voyez mon silence fait que je pourrais
dire j'aimerais vous répondre oui crois
qu'il doit en exister
ce dont je suis sûr c'est qu'il ya des
peuples qui sont saisis par le racisme
est d'une certaine façon il dit l'air
leur âme
ce garde des sceaux nous allons
retourner svp pour voir comment ce
discours était entendue y at il des
questions sur ce premier ministre
beaucoup de questions sur le terrorisme
si un directeur de société de bayonne
vous demande votre sentiment sur la
banalisation du crime politique
notamment avec le meurtre de vendredi à
bayonne
faut-il accepter que des étrangers
viennent régler leurs comptes sur le sol
français et autre question d'un
antiquaire de bruxelles pourquoi le
gouvernement français n'accepte t-il par
l'extradition des terroristes italiens
réclamé par la communauté européenne
ne craignez-vous pas en donnant l'asile
à ces réfugiés de faire de la france la
patrie du terrorisme
oui sur la banalisation du crime
politique lors de questions dans le
crime mois n'est jamais banal il doit
être poursuivi et il doit être
sanctionné et sanctionnés avec fermeté
quel qu'il soit alors que je rappellerai
simplement que dans toutes les affaires
je dis bien dans toutes les affaires qui
ont été jugés récemment dans les
dernières années que je sois en
correctionnelle où que ce soit la cour
d'assises les réquisitions
les demandes faites par l'avocat général
ont toujours été très sévère et les
condamnations prononcées par les jurés
et par les magistrats ont toujours été
sévère
alors maintenant en ce qui concerne
cette demande de l'antique heure belge à
propos des terroristes italiens des ceux
qui sont en france
je répondrai très clairement ils sont
venus en france
c'est là d'ailleurs pour une grande
partie avant 1980 et en ce qui concerne
les demandes d'extradition
nous avons en 1982 publier des critères
d'extradition équiterre l'extradition
qui respecte toutes les exigences du
droit
mais qui marque bien que si sérieusement
avec charges précises à l'appui on se
trouve en présence d'une demande à
l'encontre d'un homme qui aurait commis
un crime de sang qui aurait du sang sur
les mains
à cet instant là nous extra du rayon je
le dis très clairement je les mêmes déjà
déclaré en 1982 prenons par exemple le
cas
l'assassin d'aldo moro s'il était
réfugié en france il serait extradé
une autre question jean lui le sun
question la retraitée de
seine-saint-denis il y a beaucoup de
questions sur l'as l'abolition de la
peine de mort
est-ce démocratique d'avoir supprimé la
peine de mort alors que 70% des français
ne voulaient pas la réponse réponse est
très simple et immédiate il n'y a rien
de plus démocratique que le respect des
institutions et la peine de mort c'est
une disposition plus tôt c'est est une
disposition du code pénal le code pénal
la relève de la loi est la loi cela
relève du parlement
je vais plus loin on n'a peut-être pas
assez fait attention au fait que
l'abolition de la peine de mort a été
votée en france non seulement à
l'assemblée par une majorité qui
dépassaient la majorité de gauche mais
aussi a été voté en première lecture par
le sénat qui est chacun sait composer de
telle façon qu'il y a une majorité de
droite donc sur ce point le consensus a
été atteint
le référendum n'est pas possible en ce
qui concerne l'abolition de la peine de
mort ça n'aurait pas été constitutionnel
donc nous avons respecté la constitution
et pourquoi la france ne ratifie tenait
pas le sixième protocole de la
convention des droits de l'homme qui
rendrait l'abolition de la peine de mort
irréversible
non ça n'aurait pas nui réversible au
sens où on l'entend c'est que plus
jamais on ne pourrait la rétablir ce
n'est pas exact de la rentrée se lavant
rétabli sable par l'article 16 de la
constitution au nord non si vous me
permettez
je lui souhaite précis sur ce point cela
veut dire que l'abolition de la peine de
mort s'intègre dans l'ensemble
convention plus ça 2 cela est consacré
l'abolition comme étant un des droits de
l'homme ce n'est pas rien et je demande
à tous les français de son souvenir cela
veut dire que la totalité de l'europe
en signant cette convention a mis hors
la loi
la peine de mort alors signature
ratification je sais que ce n'est pas la
même chose signature urnes en français
signée ratifié là nous avons une
difficulté particulier je la marque très
clairement c'est une difficulté qui
tient à la constitution la question se
pose les juristes
est ce que l'article 16 est incompatible
avec la ratification
pourquoi parce que l'article 16 c'est
celui qui donne au président république
des pouvoirs exceptionnels dans des
circonstances exceptionnelles et dans le
cadre des ces pouvoirs exceptionnels
on considère qu'il peut y avoir de
nouvelles délégations la loi p alors là
nous sommes en présence d'une question
qui est une question constitutionnelle
dont on peut sortir comment mais écoutez
on peut s'en sortir très difficilement
on peut s'en sortir
en utilisant la procédure de
consultation du conseil constitutionnel
aura son avis on peut s'en sortir aussi
mais cela ne me paraît pas être le
meilleur voix en utilisant la procédure
qui est d'abord le débat parlementaire
puis l'avis du conseil constitutionnel
ça je ne crois pas que cela va de soi
mais c'est une difficulté très sérieuse
et sur laquelle les juristes
s'interrogent
je vous dirais très franchement pour ma
part je verrai une façon très simple de
résoudre la question ce serait de
supprimer l'article 16 que je considère
comme ne devant pas être dans l'arsenal
d'une démocratie
sauf que le marque entend mener
il supprimera comment il faut un
référendum une modification de la
constitution l'époque et le climat
politique monsieur devient lieu ne s'y
précipitent mans bon alors philippe
tesson pour un quart d'heure gauche je
dis bien trois quarts d'heure j'aimerais
vous interrogez essentiellement sur deux
sujets votre oeuvre d'abord comme dit
alain duhamel et ensuite les mères
porteuses et si nous en avons le temps
j'aimerais si vous le voulez bien
revient aussi sur le racisme propos de
quoi votre réponse précédente ne va pas
totalement satisfait si vous voulez on
peut commencer par là peut-être pas
parce qu'elle ment important est d'être
va parce qu'il me semble que la question
concernant votre oeuvre est plus urgente
puisque je ne partage pas votre analyse
concernant le racisme
je ne considère que je considère que les
manifestations auxquelles nous assistons
actuellement relève davantage d'une
espèce de protectionnisme ou une
sécuritaire que d'un que d'un réaction
sécuritaire que d'un véritable mouvement
raciste en fait quand je vois dans la du
racisme quotidien
la liste des profanations qui
interviennent dans les cimetières ou
quand je relève les violences qui sont
exercées difficile de dire que ça relève
du sécuritaire non il ya du racisme mais
comme il y en a toujours eu je crois
mais john provale je suis sûr à voir le
nom et si vous ne savez pas vous
interroger sur votre oeuvre
vous aviez annoncé un code pénal
monsieur le ministre
c'était il y as si je me rappelle bien
il y a il ya bientôt quatre ans trois
ans une vie mais ça c'était devant
l'assemblée lors du débat sur
l'abolition de la peine de mort or nous
vous l'avions annoncé pour l'automne
82ème je crois à cette époque que ça or
nous sommes au printemps 85 il n'y a
toujours pas de code pénal
cet ajournement m'amène à me poser une
question plus fondamentale plus larges
relatives à justement à votre oeuvre à
votre bilan est il n'entre pas du tout
d'intention polémique dans ma question
est la meilleure preuve en est dans ce
cycle
j'estime que vous avez fait beaucoup de
choses énormément de choses et même des
vous avez fait passer des réformes
extrêmement importante et que sans doute
l'histoire retiendra vous avez aboli la
peine de mort vous avez supprimé les
juridictions d'exception j'ai fait venir
etc
vous allez peut-être à peu faire abolir
l'article 16 si j'entends bien en tout
cas y contribuer le jeudi moi même ça ne
me paraissait pas la conjoncture
actuelle peut peut-être en tout cas il
s'agit essentiellement toutes ces
réformes que vous avez été l'initiateur
vous avez fait passer sont
essentiellement des réformes symbole ce
sont des réformes extrêmement
spectaculaire je répète essentiel mais
statistiquement si je puis dire
négligeable elles sont des des symboles
historiques très fort elle exprime une
un sushi philosophique très estimable un
souci moral très estimable mais elles ne
répondent pas si je puis dire ah la la
préoccupation du des citoyens et des
justiciables
elles s'inscrivent pas dans l'ordre du
quotidien sont des grammys peuvent alors
votre question finalement c'est très
important mais ce préambule est très
important car si je regarde bien il n'y
a pas de code pénal la justice du
quotidien commente bernard a quand même
depuis napoléon mais nos bras il n'y a
pas ce fameux code pénal annoncé par
monsieur badinter en 81 à 80 la justice
du quotidien toujours aussi lente et
aussi courteline elle soit à peu près le
code civil où il n'y avait pas touché
et pourtant il s'agissait de changer la
société quand vous êtes arrivé au
pouvoir quand on veut changer la société
on modifie le code civil qui date lui
aussi d'environ 200 ans les aigles même
les extraditions est un problème donc
vous flatter pour lequel vous avez fait
beaucoup vous avez finit par composer
avec alors d'un côté et c'est ça assez
voilà le sens de ma question d'un côté
nous sommes que vous ayez fait
énormément même que vous ayez fille et
vous ayez fait trop et de l'autre côté
que vous ayez fait trop peu et je
voudrais savoir pourquoi si vous vous
interrogez là dessus est ce que c'est
parce que vous avez réfléchi
est ce que c'est parce que vous êtes
modéré ce que c'est parce que je sais
pas est ce que c'est parce que monsieur
mitterrand n'est pas d'appeler ont enfin
il ya forcément une raison je voudrais
la connaître ce soir je suis un tout une
relation je ne suis pas qu'en basse et
je voulais les gérer dans ce qu'elles
sont
monsieur besson je suis très contente
d'être question j'ai failli vous
interrompre devant l'inexactitude rugby
non et puis j'ai eu un certain
contentement temps de parler d'histoire
de symboles ça me faisait plaisir alors
je vous ai laissé alors je vais vous
dire vous êtes complètement à côté de la
plaque
pardonnez moi j'en étais sûr vous êtes
complètement à côté de la plaque parce
que c'est tout à fait pardonnable dans
votre cas vous ne vivez pas la réalité
judiciaire dire que vous n'avez jamais
suivi tout ce que depuis modestement
opiniâtrement terrassement depuis trois
ans nous faisons pour améliorer le
fonctionnement de la justice mais le
code pénal monsieur le ministre
oui il voulait bien comme avait parlé de
ce que tient ensuite je passe au code
pénal et sur l'instant vierge
d'extraction mais d'abord la justice au
quotidien
ah j'oubliais vous étiez là perdu vous
sur les hauteurs non non
depuis 1982 avec un budget vous le savez
un virus 0 5%
khaled rude membres de ménagère je me
suis acharné nous nous sommes acharnés à
la chancellerie à essayer de faire
changer cette justice de la modernité
dans ce budget j'ai eu 15 %
d'augmentation en trois ans dans ce
budget
gt ça vous savez sans lui pour cent
d'accroissement de l'informatique
à la minute où je vous parle je sois
décisif vers la bureautique et
d'informatique 15% du parc national de
toutes les machines de traitement de
texte la fonction publique en justice
monsieur tesson la productivité
judiciaire elle s'est accru de 18% au
niveau des cours d'appel de 12% au
niveau des tribunaux de grande instance
au niveau les conseils du podium de 55 %
quand je dis la productivité ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on juge
beaucoup plus d'affaires sans avoir
beaucoup plus de moyens donc lieu de
chuter son vous me dites la justice les
délais nous avons demandé à tous les
magistrats
ils ont mis beaucoup du leur les
fonctionnaires ils ont répondu les
avocats s'associer aux autres pour
arriver à quoi de nouvelles procédures
allégées
une nouvelle façon de traiter les
contentieux résultat je les ai là je
vous disais la production s'est
augmentée je vais ajouter en chef
d'entreprise
délais de livraison se sont raccourcis
1984 il fallait ça s'est passé au mur si
peu de choses c'est la première fois
depuis dix ans qu'on inverse la tendance
de 20 mois et demi dix-huit mois et demi
au niveau des cours d'appel dans leur
ensemble
l'ensemble des cours d'appel pour
l'année 1984 ce tribunal de grande
instance de 13,7 à deux heures mais on
n'en est pas encore à expédier les
affaires plus vite comme les reçoit et
maintenant on n'est pas sans réaction du
site on n'est pas à réduire le stock des
à berne et à la résorption d'un certain
toutes les cours d'appel non dans j'ai
dit ça c'est la moyenne nationale on le
progrès est partout sur la moyenne
nationale mais dans certaines
juridictions
on est allé plus loin pour une grasse ou
magie 2 annonce si j'étais à rennes
j'étais à grenoble j'étais à poitiers il
y a partout partout des progrès et cela
voyez vous je crois que c'est immersif
hier qu'il y ait un nouvel état d'esprit
dans la façon de considérer la justice
institutions l'enseignant j'en parle
mais en sport cette chance que j'ai ce
soir ça n'intéresse personne en dehors
des professionnels mais c'est pour vous
dire que je suis aussi ça intéresse tout
le monde ne joue pas réussi ce que mort
à bord d informatique parce que
l'informatique sert la justice ce n'est
pas pour le plaisir de parler
informatiques tout en maintenant je
n'arrive au côté là c'est pour vous dire
quelle daube loin c'est l'été dans ces
régions en train d'y travailler
non parce que les délais ça compte quand
on attend un divorce acompte pour
régulariser m'ont dit sa situation
quand on attend de récupérer son
appartement ça compte quand on attend
une indemnité de licenciement
ça compte beaucoup donc ces batailles là
pour la vie quotidienne des français ça
compte
on les a menés alors maintenant parlons
du cocktail au code pénal
j'étais son puisque vous êtes tellement
intéressé à la réaction je vais vous
faire plaisir
nous avons fini la partie générale par
contre fini les deux premiers livres
ça fait 4 110 articles alors c'est vrai
c'est vrai que ce n'est pas une mince
tâche c'est vrai que maintenant il va
partir au conseil d'état et je vais le
soumettre au conseil des ministres
les lignes générales du code pénal ça ne
sera d'ailleurs pas terminée mais je
consomme donc elle devait dans le
courant avril
car moi j'ai fini les trois premiers
lille enfin nous la commission du code
pénal et la direction affaires
criminelles la chanson raï log est prête
en fait l'amendement l'examinera avant
la lucette à propos du fait là nous
sommes en présence d'une exigence vous
avez dit code pénal de napoléon c'est
vrai on a encore d'une certaine manière
que napoléon très changer très modifiée
mais enfin c'est encore le code pénal de
napoléon ça n'est plus le groupe final
de notre temps alors le code pénal de
notre temps qu'est ce qui sert pénal
c'est celui qui correspond à la fois aux
exigences de la défense de la société et
en même temps celui qui traduit la
philosophie d'une société savez moi le
code pénal je ne peux pas le considérer
comme le code pénal d'une majorité ou
d'une législature et le code pénal des
français ou sinon il n'est rien alors
comment y parvenir
je pense à une procédure parlementaire
nécessairement différente et originale
pourquoi parce que sinon vous imaginez
avec la partie sur téléthon sera leur
bientôt les 500 articles
alors comment faire pour à la fois faire
touche au code pénal sur le code de tous
les français et faire que le parlement
puisse le conduire à son terme
et bien quand l'avant projet sera pas
circoncis mist est devenu projet il sera
déposé à l'assemblée
alès anglais le rapporteur il sera nommé
pourra à ce moment là j'en ai parlé que
monsieur power j'en ai parlé que le
président de la commission des lois de
l'assemblée nationale avec le président
de la commission des lois du sénat
tout le monde est d'accord national maso
nous allons avoir une commission qui
existent et qui sera mixte c'était que
vous aurez à la fois des députés et des
sénateurs représentant toutes les
tendances
tous les partis et qui travailleront
avec le rapporteur de façon à ce qu on
voit bien les points d'accord ils seront
infiniment plus nombreux monsieur tu es
sans que les points de désaccord j'en
suis convaincu et aussi et quelques
points de désaccord j'ajoute qu'il faut
cette commission puisse entendre des
experts des psychiatres important
des surveillants de prison qu'il faut
aussi qu'on entende des professeurs de
droit
bref toute une série d'auditions par les
d'information début je dirais volontiers
j'aurais souhaité qu'elle soit publique
et puis et bien au parlement de
travailler alors vous direz mais fut un
terreau ne serai plus là d'abord je ne
sais pas en tout cas ça n'a pas
d'importance ce qui compte
j'aurais fait ma copie ce qui compte
c'est qu'une méthode
ce qui compte c'est que ce soit
l'expression de notre temps ils ont été
noyés qu'un parlement aura le courage
politique à la veille d'élections
législatives d'aborder les problèmes de
sécurité et que vous n'aurez pas autre
chose que le travail en commission mais
ce sera déjà considérable je n'aurais
pas ça ne peut pas être autre chose que
cette expression pour la nation soeur
suivante les incursions mais ce sera
chaud craque aussi carrière le droit
pénal droit pénal de la santé le rappel
à l'environnement le droit pénal des
transports c'est une encyclopédie
donc cela se poursuivra mais ce que je
voudrais marquer c'est que j'étais à la
recherche de ce qui est dans notre
société la société française aujourd'hui
contredit tellement conflictuelle
tellement divisée
j'étais à la recherche de ce qui
constitue la base le shom cette société
ce sur quoi nous sommes tous à
l'exception de quelques traits d'un tout
petit nombre d'extrémistes
je me tous d'accord j'ai notre société
elle à un consensus
elle repose sur les droits de l'homme et
les droits de l'homme
quand on est amis on se dit c'est quoi
c'est d'abord le respect de la personne
humaine c'est la prise en considération
de la personne humaine est alors par
rapport à ce code napoléon que vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure vous le savez
c'est la société 1810 l'ordre étant ici
toute la partie est consacrée
est ce qu'on appelle le droit spécial eh
bien elle est axée sur le respect de la
personne humaine celle que ce code pénal
c'est le code pénal de la défense de la
personne humaine l'intégrité physique
mais aussi la dignité aussi la
personnalité mais aussi l'intimité
bref la personne humaine dans tous ses
attributs
alors quand je vous disais moi je me
fais une joie d'atteindre les jours
heureux des travaux avec la commission
mais
croyez moi je suis sûr que nous en
sortir alors on parle un peu des mères
porteuses si vous voulez rejoint la
personne humaine vous avez pris à vienne
au cours de la réunion des ministres
européens de la justice une position
extrêmement tolérante libéral à vis à
vis du problème de la procréation
artificielle allant même jusqu'à dire
que vous souhaitiez que les mères
célibataires puisse recourir à ce
procédé
et vous avez pris de la même façon il à
vis du poème particulier des mères
porteuses
une position également très très libre
et très libérale mère-porteuse c'est à
dire les maires qui porte un enfant qui
n'est pas le leur alors à ce propos je
voudrais que vous acceptiez de répondre
à quelques brèves question que je j'ai
je veux vous poser est destinée à
préciser votre réponse destinée à
préciser votre pensée
la première question est la suivante
pour peut-être y répondre successivement
cible et non pas de façon groupée ne pas
de façon groupée première question il
voit la première question est la
suivante pourquoi
et tout le monde se le demande avez vous
pris une position aussi avancé à la fois
dans l'esprit bien que ce soit conforme
à votre philosophie est aussi dans le
temps alors que vous aviez promis sinon
vous vous étiez engagé à procéder à une
large consultation de toutes les
organismes toutes les personnes
intéressées et alors que beaucoup de
gens tout la plupart même de vos
partenaires intéressés par cette affaire
était sinon hostile en tout cas pour le
moins réservé par exemple les ministres
du gouvernement monsieur hervé madame du
foie le comité d'éthique médicale etc
la question c'est pourquoi vous avez
annoncé ça alors qu'une consultation
devait s'ouvrir ces temps ci pourquoi si
vite
nous sommes à vienne il s'agit de la
conférence européenne des droits de
l'homme sujet parmi d'autres procréation
artificielle génétique droits de l'homme
rapporteur la france présent celui qui
vous parle nous évoquions les droits de
l'homme
il y a un instant une question comme
celle là j'ai avancé ma réflexion est
gelée soumise comme une réflexion je
vous signale que
vos du conseil de l'europe il ne s'agit
que d'un comité de réflexion
donc c'est une réflexion la concertation
elle interviendra la concertation elle
aura lieu
et à ce moment là le gouvernement sera
amené votre intervention langage areva
le gouvernement mais ma réflexion est
une réflexion qui est personnel je
marque cependant que vis-à-vis des mères
porteuses
elle engage le garde des sceaux parce
que le garde des sceaux est directement
interpellé immédiatement par la question
c'est pourquoi parce que non la mère
porteuse et dit ce que c'était supposons
que la mère porteuse couche et que
l'autre mère viennent déclare l'enfant
sous son nom là on est en présence d'une
infraction pénale
mais savez monsieur tesson et alors moi
on m'a posé la question déjà
donc je voudrais pas me dérober est ce
que vous entendez poursuivre j'ai
répondu non non parce que franchement
est ce qu'on imagine un instant là il
faut être réaliste et 5
est ce qu'on imagine un instant juste
une infraction criminelle une vieille
infractions chea l'ancien régime
supposition de l'enfant vous voyez ça
dans le box la mère porteuse
la mère adoptive le bébé le père le mari
tout cela dans le box des accusés avec
l'avocat général qui aurait demandé des
réquisitions et j'aurais seulement son
nom
c'est tout à fait un souci cela dit vous
n'avez pas à poser le problème qu'en
termes juridiques et c'est d'ailleurs ma
deuxième question lui est posée si par
ailleurs en termes moraux et financiers
si je puis dire c'est à si vous avez dit
le jeune je considère qu'il y à delhi en
face une embellie en tout cas que le
recours de contenir que le recours à la
mère porteuse est condamnable
lorsqu'il s'accompagne d'une transaction
commerciale dire non non vous l'avez pas
dit non l'édition et des insultes à la
main j'étais tout à fait précis je veux
l'être encore parce que ce sont les
choses il faut bien éclaircir un jeudi
n'est pas de poursuites pénales
envisageables contre une mère porteuse
et contre la mère adoptive valais
poursuit donc c'est exclu 2une un accord
je peux appeler ça un contrat un accord
comme celui là il est nul il est nul
parce qu'ils portent sur la personne
humaine
aucun n'a aucune valeur et j'ai dit à
vienne jamais le
s'il ne doit prêter sa force
une telle convention sonia en clair que
si la mère porteuse décide de conserver
l'enfant l'autre ne pourra pas venir
comment l'angleterre demandé je ne sais
pas tu laisses à la livraison mais
demandez est-ce qu'on lui remette
l'enfant non le juge civil ne pourrait
pas il ne dira pas voilà sous astreinte
vous devez non d'envoyer la liberté de
la mère porteuse reste entière en ce qui
concerne l'argent lui-même toute remise
d'argent ici elle n'a pas de cause
ça veut dire que si on garde l'enfant je
ne pense pas qu'on puisse réclamer
l'argent c'est une zone de non droit a
servi lors du droit mais si on ne le
garde pas vous considère qu'on garde
l'argent si on ne garde pas c'est à dire
de garde si la mère porteuse ne garde
pas l'enfant vous concevez qu'elles
prennent l'argent c'est une question
importante mais à cet égard aussi vous
êtes je vais it à l'heure dans une
absence de contrat non mais la question
est ce que vous concevez moralement
en tout cas que l'on garde l'argent que
la mère porteuse qui rend l'enfant
prenne l'argent et gardent l'enfant
je vous ai répondu avec beaucoup de
précision dans ce cas là celles qui ont
versé l'argent n'aura aucune action pour
pouvoir leur éclat mais je suis pas un
pur produit sous pression je me suis tue
un état de droit on savait qu'il y ait
quand même transactions financières
entre l'une et l'autre pilote je ne le
conçois pas je le dis très simplement si
cela se produit le jeu d'action à la
sauce lui il n'y aura aucune pause si
j'ai tenté d'obtenir du juge et partie
l'attribution de la convention arabe a
dit l'agent met alors à temps des signes
dans légion sur les intermédiaires
alors là aussi j'ai dit très clairement
de lamine faye ce que chacun est maître
de son corps absolument
chacun est maître de la même façon
qu'eux notons en présence de conditions
qui sont illicites pas ce qu'on va faire
de conventions sur le corps d'autrui
de la même manière on ne veut pas
profiter de telles conventions ou de
telles actions
c'est à dire que tous les professionnels
tous les intermédiaires qui viendrait à
se mêler de ce genre d'accord entre deux
mers tout cela a eu ton sous le coup de
la loi pénale et des poursuites et à des
ententes alors par loyer ma position de
l'enfant si vous voulez parce que nous
parlons des mers l'a déjà là la loi sur
l'avortement était une loi très égoïste
par rapport à l'enfant et pour cause et
à plus forte raison 7,7
cette pratique
cette pratique est une pratique
extrêmement intégristes qui ne prend pas
forcément en compte les intérêts de
l'enfant
alors je vous demande si vous avez
forcément réfléchi au problème
quelles sont les garanties auxquelles
vous pensez de l'identité de l'enfant
notamment par rapport aux pairs ce qui
est un problème nouveau
quelles sont d'autre part quelle est la
façon dont vous résolvez le problème
éventuel delà de la déchirure de
l'enfant entre entre deux mers la mère
biologique et et l'autre mère la mère
sociale
troisièmement est-ce que vous avez
réfléchi et sûrement au problème du
rejet éventuel de l'enfant par exemple
s'il était mal formés ou pour toute
autre hypothèse par l'une ou l'autre ou
par les deux maires à la fois et quelles
garanties juridiques envisagez-vous sur
ce plan la question oui mais je n'ai
répondre très précisément j'en ai une
autre sur ce sujet je l'aï je la pose
maintenant parce que l économie se la
posent matin les connexes qu'elle est la
mère elle est d'ailleurs au coeur du
problème qu'elle est la mère selon vous
est ce que c'est la mère qui porte
l'enfant ou est ce que c'est la mère qui
déclare l'enfant à l'état civil alors
vous pouvez me répondre
monsieur le ministre que l'instinct
maternel n'existe que l'instinct
maternel n'existe pas c'est pas
forcément un procès d'intention auquel
cas ma question à valeur pour l'instant
maternelle c'est à moi d'autre part en
ce qui concerne maintenant l'action que
vous avez posé mais monsieur tesson tout
est simple derrière l'apparenté
complexité tout est simple pourquoi
parce que vous avez une situation qui
est sensiblement identique dans
l'adoption l'adoption la femme abandonne
son enfant
mais l'attention je savais que par
convention il peut y avoir dans ce
domaine une déclaration de volonté et
vous savez qu'il peut y avoir une
adoption par convention savait qu'on
peut aller à l'état civil que les deux
parents peuvent dire nous sommes
disposés à consentir l'adoption et même
au profit de monsieur et madame x droit
de repentir
je lui indique trois mois mais ici vous
avez une mère naturelle une mère
pardonnez moi l'expression adoptive très
bien le droit de l'adoption nous permet
de répondre vous me dit qu'elle est la
mère je vous réponds dans l'adoption qui
est la mère celle qui a adopté dans le
schéma de la mère porteuse est de celles
qui recueillera il y aura nécessairement
adoption ou me dit le père mais le père
dans ce qui nous intéresse c'est le père
qui je crois que c'est cela que vous
évoquez est le père de l'enfant qui lie
à une assimilation est le père de
l'enfant
dans ce cas là c'est son enfant et sa
femme c'est la mer par adoption notre
droit ils répondent à peine trop légère
modification encore je suis même pas sûr
qu'elle soit absolument indispensable
donc nous avons le moule juridique et
c'est cela quand j'ai parlé une fois
d'adoption par anticipation
ça veut dire tout simplement que nous
étions en présence d'une adoption
vous voyez le père est toujours le père
la mère
vous avez la même dualité que dans
l'adoption à partir de ce moment là le
problème
il est dans la conscience il est dans la
conscience et légiférer
je vous dis très franchement au terme de
la concertation nous verrons mais moi
personnellement je n'y suis pas encore
je crois que nous avons des possibilités
de réponses juridiques
à l'heure actuelle dans notre droit et
il faut s'abstenir comme le dit très
bien
le doyen carbonnier de faire des textes
là où la morale et les moeurs peuvent
répondre monsieur miss nous retournons
svp pour d'autres questions jean louis
le cem oui beaucoup de questions aussi
ce soir sur le droit des victimes
d'accidents de la route
on trouve la justice trop faible je vous
donne cette question trois de mes
enfants ont été assassinés par un
chauffard en état d'ivresse c'est la
principale cause d'insécurité pourquoi
les pannes restent elles aussi légères
et une autre personne qui trouve la
justice dans lé cadre du droit des
victimes d'accidents de la route trop
lente
que pensez vous d'une accidentés de la
route handicapés à 60% qui en est à sa
4e expertise médicale et qui a touché
depuis quatre ans et demi
fran ais je trouve que ce sont des
situations qui sont humainement
intolérable je le dis très clairement
humainement intolérante en ce qui
concerne d'abord les accidents de la
circulation c'est vrai que à l'heure
actuelle c'est la plus grande cause
d'insécurité d'insécurité physique il ya
près de 12000 un peu moins les choses
vont un peu mieux mais pas encore bien
douze mille personnes par an qui sont
tués sur les routes
il y a environ 280 milles qui sont
blessés on imagine ce que ça signifie
une hécatombe comme celle-là et des
pertes humaines
une charge d un coût de 80 milliards de
francs par an c'est certainement un des
mots principe pendant le soufre alors
maintenant en ce qui concerne les peines
elle-même jugée reprises par voie de
circulaire
j'ai demandé aux parquets que s'agissant
d'homicide qui sont commis sur la route
par des personnes en état d'ivresse ou
qui violent délibérément les règles
fondamentales de la prudence reste
comportements asociaux dans ce cas là
que l'on demande des peines très très
sévères
c'est aux magistrats évidemment du siège
de décider mais ces réquisitions sont
sévères
maintenant en ce qui concerne les
victimes et tout à l'heure je n'ai pas
eu l'occasion de le dire à monsieur
besson
en ce qui concerne les victimes dans ce
que nous avons fait le parlement pour la
session nous à la chancellerie
ce qui a été fait au profit des victimes
est considérable et si j'ai une fierté
secret personnel c'est d'avoir porté
avec le parlement le droit français au
plus haut niveau lors peut-être juste au
dessous des suées loi en ce qui concerne
la protection des victimes et que ce
soit au niveau de l'accueil
l'information les garanties les
indemnisations
aujourd'hui deux fois plus de monde deux
fois plus de crédit dans mon pauvre
budget les associations j'ai été le
premier des ministres de la justice à
inscrire au budget à inscrire au budget
une ligne en faveur des victimes le
premier a trait à la chancellerie
un bureau des victimes le premier enfin
à me
à vouloir un autre avait fait renvoyer
mais il s'était malheureusement arrêtée
en cours de route
à vouloir que s'agissant des victimes
d'accidents de la circulation
eh bien on prenne mieux en compte les
besoins de leur indemnisation alors là
je vais être très clair quand la loi
nouvelle sera votée elle a été votée par
l'assemblée va être soumise au sénat
tous les piétons et particulièrement les
vieilles personnes et les enfants seront
garantis et hante une indemnisation
même chose en ce qui concerne les
cyclistes parce qu'il ne représente pas
le danger sur la route que je suis reste
responsable de leur fait
mais si ils sont vite et incident on ne
fait pas des français qui ont évité les
mettre dans l'accusation on ne
s'interroge pas sur le comportement
d'une vieille dame de 72 ans en se
disant est ce qu'elle a traversé au
forage au feu est au vert au fond on ne
s'interroge pas on ne fait pas des
procès comme j'en ai vu faire dans
lequel on dit un enfant un enfant de 7
ans sort de l'école il ya un
encombrement il l'a essaye de passer à
travers les voitures
la voiture ne le vois pas qui arrive
envers son enfant
à ce moment là on s'interroge est ce que
c'est de la faute de l'enfant qu'est ce
qu'on lui reproche dans ce cas là
l'enfant
cette conduit comme un enfant cela ne
sera plus et quand cette loi sera votée
et bien transaction accélérer
l'indemnisation améliorée
je peux dire que nous nous envient
parlement et moi-même tout ce que nous
pouvions en faveur des victimes mais là
puisque ce soir je suis athée gens je le
dis très clairement ça n'est rien ce
n'est rien si on ne prend pas conscience
sur la route de ce que l'on conduit un
engin mortel que pour gagner quelques
secondes on est en danger sa vie la vie
des siens et la vie des autres et
vraiment je crois que les français
maintenant doivent le réaliser
est-ce que vous est-ce que vous
condamner l'apologie de la vitesse qui
est fait dans certaines publicités
est-ce que vous avez absolument je
considère que c'est là aller vers le
pire je considère que d'inciter appuyé
sur l'accélérateur quand on sait le
délai qu'il faut pour s'arrêter
c'est véritablement poussé en patrouille
et je pense les plus jeunes conducteurs
vers des performances que ni les routes
ni les voitures ni eux mêmes ne devrais
même songé à évoquer dans d'autres pays
que nous aux états unis dans les pays
scandinaves les voitures sont vendues
sur la sur la durée sur la sécurité
pas sur la vitesse est ce que vous êtes
d'avis de changer on dit que si
l'argument publicitaire ont dit que
c'est un mal latin je réponds que pour
la france
c'est en tout cas à coup sûr à nos pires
fléaux
est ce que ce n'est pas le prix à payer
pour l'industrie automobile en crise je
ne vois pas d'après ce que je crois
savoir volvo marche très bien
et d'après ce que je crois savoir
chrysler il me semble à bien remonter la
pente aux états unis et pourtant ça
n'est pas en augmentant les plafonds de
vitesse mais c'est ainsi albert du roy
luminosa peyroche brièvement et vous
répondez brièvement car il y avait
beaucoup de goût de question qui se pose
est ce que le front national est une
organisation raciste
monsieur le pen dit qui l'est
républicain chez le pen dit qu'ils les
démocrates
moi j'écoute je regarde ton temps
et les discours qu'y sont tenues dans
les meetings du front national à quoi
faut-il appel
consciemment ou inconsciemment je n'en
sais rien mais qu'est ce qu'ils font le
v dans les coeurs humains les patients
on évoquait la xénophobie et trop
facilement aussi le frère jumeau le
racisme quotidien
est ce que le front national est
passible de la loi non alors je reviens
ce que je disais à partir de ce moment
là quand on est démocrate il faut penser
aux fondements de la démocratie ça ne se
résume pas dans les institutions ça se
résume dans une simple proposition le
respect de l'autre je dis souvent la
première des libertés c'est la liberté
de l'autre
et j'ajoute la première obligation c'est
de respecter la dignité de l'autre alors
se dire démocrate s'affirmer républicain
et en même temps faire appel à des
passions qui contredisent le fondement
même de la république et de la
démocratie
ça me paraît singulièrement
contradictoires et parfois denses
est-ce qu'on peut condamner sur le plan
des principes une façon aussi vigoureuse
le racisme sans aussi tenté et ses
forces et réussir à juguler les deux
causes du développement du racisme que
sont la sécurité au chômage il faut
lutter contre l'insécurité chômage
évidemment et il faut lutter contre le
racisme mais il faut avoir le courage de
dire il y a chômage et il existe une
petite délinquance urbaine qui est très
porteuse d'insécurité il faut combattre
combattre les causes peuvent être les
causes par une politique économique
combattent aussi la source de la vacance
par la politique de prévention
une fois que c'est fait et on ne fera
jamais assez
on doit dire même s'il y a insécurité
chômage pas de bouc émissaire pas de
commodités pas de transfert est pas
d'appel à ses patients que j'évoquais la
politique de prévention très bien pour
la petite délinquance et la politique de
répression l'un des reproches qui vous
ai fait le plus souvent c'est que la
petite délinquance on n'a plus le temps
de s'en occuper
dans les commissariats on clique un
cambrioleur un voleur à la tire
on le relâche aussitôt parce qu'on n'a
pas le temps de taper à la machine les
rapports monsieur roy
voilà c'est la seule lecture que je
ferai j'entends quelquefois parlait
souvent comme de vrais spies a souvent
parlé du laxisme entre guillemets de la
justice et en particulier du mien une
première observation fondamentale ce
n'est pas moi qui change ce sont les
jurés et ce sont les magistrats
alors maintenant une constatation très
simple 1981 1984
moi je suis l'évolution des choses la
justice française
plus de poursuites en 1984 qu'en 1980
plus de condamnations en 1984 qu'en 1980
plus de condamnations à des peines de
prison en 1984 qu'en 1980 plus de monde
en prison en 1984 en 1980 c'est une des
justices les plus sévères d'europe et
pour qu'on me tue une idée de ce qu'est
la réalité de la justice française
j'ai fait faire le calcul en année en
1981 peines d'emprisonnement je parle
pas de réclusion criminelle
je parle correctionnel 74 1780 deux
années de prison ont été prononcées en
1981 en 1983 78000 au lieu de 74 1930
année quant au nombre des condamnés
en ce qui concerne 10 20 ans les
feuilles 28% en ce qui concerne les
condamnés à perpétuer
g
8 pour ça c'est un constat vous savez
monsieur du roi alors simplement avec
aujourd'hui 44000 003 personnes dans les
prisons françaises
quand j'entends parler de l'axis je lui
mets quoi
mais il rêve nos concitoyens mais ils ne
vont jamais dans les pas de revendiquer
le qualificatif de ministres répressif
non je rappelle encore une fois que je
ne juge pas monsieur du roi que c'est
moi qui ai fait voter les peines de
substitution parce que la courte peine
d'emprisonnement
je n'y crois pas je sais que le jeune
délinquant rencontrera dans la prison le
le professionnel qui sortira avec
l'adresse dans la poche qu'il ira
ensuite avec s'établit dès lors pourquoi
n'y a pas de prison pour les jeunes je
suis roi les prisons françaises ne sont
pas l'honneur de notre pays et je le dis
avec beaucoup de regrets nous sommes
j'ai vu cette humiliation
cette humiliation au conseil de l'europe
d'apprendre du ministre hollandais qui
avait fait faire le calcul que le tous
les pays
4 11 pays d'europe du nord gestion celui
qui dépense est le moins par tête de
prisonniers savez l'état de nos prisons
j'ai trouvé en arrivant 29 mille places
pour 41 mille prisonniers
j'en ai construit plus que quiconque on
la porte et vous êtes vol moins de place
qu'il n'ya de prisonniers en plus j'ai
reçu ce prix de 1000 places plus de
place et il ya comme un témoin je dis
quelquefois en riant jamais cru que je
deviendrais à vauban pénitentiaire et
que je passerai tant de temps à
m'interroger sur l' architecture
carcérale
nous avons construit à peu près cinq
cent cinquante places par an moyenne
avant était de 350 400 ont construit
pour moins cher
nous sommes à plus de 31000 il ya 44
mille pas je n'y ai je suis pas encore
alors je dois dire que dans les grands
travaux à venir
le premier ministre a accepté de
faire une enveloppe particulière pour
les grisons mais le retard est immense
il l'a j'ajoute que quand il s'agit
d'implanter une prison quelle que soit
la couleur politique gérée action
municipale qui est toujours la même
celle du roi on entend les français
réclament et la passion sévérité fermeté
en juin de dire ce qui est mais quand il
s'agit d'implanter dans une commune mais
ne brisant alors là c'est toujours la
commune d'à côté et ça est vrai pour
toutes les couleurs politiques
viens voir bin non c'est pas possible
vous pouvez pas mais c'est incroyable
vous leurrez pas qu'on caserne de crs
oui pardon j'ai beau expliquer mais une
brison qu'est ce que ça veut dire si on
s'en évade premiers soins de celui qui
sera de 700 d'aller passer quand il n'y
a aucun danger non pas de prison pas de
prison mais des prisonniers que nous
allons au début de votre de cette
émission vous avez rendu un hommage aux
juges au courage des juges en rappelant
que certains d'entre elles avaient payé
leur vie je suis sûr que beaucoup de
gens se sont étonnés que n'ayez pas
rendu le même hommage aux policiers je
l'aurais fait volontiers si j'avais été
ministre de l'intérieur ce sont des
sommes dues en effet risquent leur vie
pour nous tous mais c'était déchets du
roi règne et pour votre corporation bien
ce que vous avez entendu au début ce que
j'ai entendu au début c'était une mise
en accusation des juges d'instruction
j'ai rappelé ce qu'était les fonctions
de l'instruction les responsabilités et
les risques des juges d'instruction qui
était normal qu'à ce moment là je salue
avec regret le mec chagrin la mort de
deux d'entre eux tous les commissaires
tomber tous les officiers de police
tombe et méritent également l'attention
à cet instant c'était les juges est-ce
qu'il est plus grave à vos yeux de
dessiner un policier un gardien de la
paix que d' assassiner quelqu'un d'autre
j'ai du roi j'avais toutes les victimes
sont également pitoyable la
discrimination dans ce domaine
ce n'est pas concevable vous ne
comprenez donc pas l'attitude des gens
qui disent il faudrait renforcer les
peines lorsque c'est un policier qui est
qui est victime non là je crois qu'il
faudrait en sera autrement c est parce
que il y à des personnes plus exposés ça
n'a rien à voir avec le chagrin
qu'engendre la mort je les dis toutes
les morts sont également pitoyable et
toutes les victimes méritent la même
considération
est ce que vous êtes favorable au
renforcement des effectifs et des moyens
de la police
je suis convaincu que mon ami pierre
joxe s'en préoccupe
je suis en tout cas convainc pas alors
je vous répondrai à vos dix ans
volontiers mais je suis encore plus
favorable en ma qualité de ministre de
la justice à l'accroissement du budget
de la justice est ce qu'il ne vous
arrive pas de regretter cette loi
d'amnistié de 1981 qui a mis en liberté
des terroristes d'action directe
non c'est une loi qui permet terre sous
certaines conditions
monsieur du roi je vous répondrai pas
dans les roues du prophète les yeux
regarde en avant
jamais en arrière j'irai plus simplement
il y a des moments où la générosité
aussi un pays
la dni ch'ti a été généreuse pas
tellement plus généreuse croyez moi
qu'en 1974
mais dieu sait qu'on en a fait sorte de
monstre de fantasmes collectifs
je me rappelle encore la mer me disant
toi qui fais libérée tu combien de
milliers de civils et ça c'est pas ça ce
que je veux dire c'est que un choix
avait été fait un choix qui était
politique
c'est vrai qu'il n'avait pas cette
époque commis les crimes aussi graves
que ceux qui ont été imputés dessus et
la main étaient perdus j'ai dit à la
tribune de l'assemblée
je vibre en garde ceux qui ne
comprendraient pas sans savoir que ce
sera la fermeté la plus grande à leur
encontre
et vous savez monsieur y aura peut-être
vous ne le savez pas il y a à l'heure
actuelle plus d'homme d'action directe
dans les prisons qu'avant et les
réquisitions les condamnations
vous savez ce qu elles ont été très
dures c'était une bonne loi n'était pas
une bonne loi vous savez le terme de
bonne ou de mauvaise loi c'était une loi
qui a été votée par l'assemblée et par
le sénat après la commission mixte
paritaire les deux il faut croire que le
parlement l'a trouvée bonnes nouvelles
récentes et la richesse de la politique
comme vous disiez tout à l'heure mais
dans ce cas là cet été elle aussi aux
erreurs est la suivante c'était une
erreur croyants c'est vrai il y avait je
vous le disais la cette indication
je vous rappelle d'ailleurs qu'en ce qui
concerne les bretons corses pendant un
certain temps
guadeloupéen pendant un temps plus long
les bars que eux mais je parle pas là du
terrorisme qui vient d'ailleurs
l'apaisement a été acquis sur direct
longtemps été en sommeil
et puis on a vu réapparaître donc que ne
croyait pas que ce soit à paris ça
engagé la légère ou perdu est ce que
pour lutter contre le terrorisme qui
devient des grands problèmes de la femme
ps que pour lutter contre le terrorisme
vous êtes favorable à des procédures
d'exception
non vous le savez bien d'ailleurs
d'aucune sorte
non les contrôles d'identité les
contrôles de sel dans la rue léopold ii
va brûler ce soit pour lutter contre le
terrorisme
vous savez le reste a généralement sont
armés de fort bon passeport et
d'excellents papier je ne crois pas que
carlos se promène sans papiers à
supposer qu'il se promène un jour en
faire ça n'est pas dans ce ce n'est pas
dans cette direction là qu'il faut
s'orienter la lutte contre le terrorisme
elle passe par une police très bien
organisée très spécialisées très
efficace avec une coopération
internationale qui elle est également
effective et je vous dirais que de tout
cela je ne suis pas responsable j'ajoute
que je ne suis même pas allé cette
action je sais qu'elle est conduite et
je sais qu'elle est conduite avec la
dernière fermeté alors vous me dites
lois d'exception et peut-être vous
pensez même juridiction d'exception
j'aurais cependant vous et pourquoi
indépendamment de tout
question comme raison très simple quand
quand on traduit un terroriste devant
une cour d'assises
parce que derrière toutes les
revendications lieu outre eux ce sont
des cris ce sont les moeurs ce sont des
assassinats ce sont des prises d'otage
ce sont l'utilisation détruit ce sont
des crimes et bien quand ils sont
traduits devant une cour d'assises qui
les jugent le peuple le pays ses
représentants les jurés vous moi et le
verdict à ce moment là il a une force
morale et il a une force politique bien
plus grande que n'importe quelle
décision d'une juridiction d'exception
dont ira toujours que cette décision a
été dictée par le pouvoir politique
et j'entends déjà les clameurs à
l'audience lors de l'audience là c'est
le pays c'est le pays qui condamnent les
quand il y a eu récemment
vous l'avez vue des condamnations très
sévères qui ont été prononcées dans des
affaires de terrorisme international
vous en souvenez pas si longtemps eh
bien personne n'a rien dit en ce qui
concerne le verdict je lui posais un
instant ils ont été vus juridiction
d'exception avec un scandale une
décision dictée pour des raisons
politiques là le pays par an et la voix
du pays est bien en justice si tu ne
vois qu'il ya plus de force qu aucune et
c'est pour cela que je ne crois pas
aujourd'hui sur l'extraction à part
toutes les autres raisons je vais faire
un cours de droit
vous avez dit il ya quelques semaines à
france inter une phrase qui m'a pas
étonné le fonds de commerce
insécurité n'est pas un fonds de
commerce que la gauche puisse utiliser
alors tout ça veut dire que le problème
de l'insécurité n'est pas un vrai
problème est un problème pour le pays
mais que la gauche n'est pas capable
d'affronter que j'évoquais là c'était
l'exploitation de l'insécurité c'est à
dire le fait de se servir de
l'insécurité comme arme politique
pourquoi parce que inévitablement on
regarde ceux qui peuplent les prisons
turin quand vous parlais tout à l'heure
vous savez c'est assez rarement bien que
ça arrive des fils du chirurgien c'est
assez rarement
ce sur le verso desquels les condyles
bonnes fées se sont penchées - je
regarde de ceux qui se trouvent dans les
prisons
vous avez une grande proportion de
chômeurs une forte proportion dit les
traits quasiment pas de formation
professionnelle monsieur du roi bref je
pourrais continuer je vais pas faire du
misérabilisme
je fais un constat bref ce précisément
qui ont valu à alors je dis très
nettement à partir de ce moment là le
problème devient beaucoup pour nous les
causes sociales voiliers et c'est pour
ça quand vous parliez de l'exploitation
de la sécurité vous pensiez aux grands
leaders de l'opposition par exemple
est-ce qu'ils l'exploitent la sécurité
vous voulez que je vous fasse un
florilège de citations de ce que j'ai
entendu en trois ans et demi au
parlement rendez vous où devrait il faut
surtout pas faire de généralisation il y
à cet égard des hommes qui mesure très
bien le danger de l'exploitation de la
sécurité puis hier quelques démagogues à
droite qui sont là et dieu
croyez-moi exploite autant qu'ils le
peuvent la sécurité avec des accents qui
ne sont pas très sensiblement différents
de ceux j'ai le regret de dire qu
emploie monsieur le pen mais ils ne sont
pas nombreux il y en a quelques-uns faut
le savoir
en ce qui concerne la sphère barbie je
répondrai la même façon que je ne parle
jamais des affaires en cours
simplement quant au délai peut si c'est
que d'après ce que la presse en a publié
l'instruction s'achève donc en ce qui
concerne le jugement
il devrait intervenir ça dépend
évidemment du déroulement de la peinture
je n'ai pas sur ce point donné d'autres
précisions
ancien la retransmission vous allez
changer de ville je n'ai rien dit sur la
transmission
parce que c'est un bon jeu pas sur le
bon en ce qui concerne en ce qui
concerne la retransmission
non j'ai en charge il est bien ce qui
concernait la retransmission en direct
et en intégrale d'un procès mais je me
suis beaucoup interrogée
et c'est vrai
que ma pensée a évolué en ce qui
concerne un très important est très
difficile de la l'enregistrement et de
la retransmission journal parlé le soir
des débats judiciaires parce que je me
disais mais voyons l'audience est
ouverte journalistes entre librement
c'est une garantie des libertés il faut
que la presse soit présente dans les
grands procès pourquoi est ce qu'après
tout les caméras n'y serai pas et puis
ensuite à mesure que j'écoutais car j'ai
beaucoup écouté d'amis j'ai beaucoup
écouté d'hommes de justice de
professionnels j'ai écouté aussi des
justiciables aussi écouter des juristes
de télévision j'ai compris que il y
avait là un risque un risque pour le
fonctionnement de la justice et un
risque pour les justiciables
d'abord je parlais des justiciables et
là ce sont des joueuses de télévision de
province qui monte des folies vous savez
la retransmission
mais d'un petit fait divers comme ça à
l'audience correctionnelle dans une
ville de province pour celui qui
comparaîtra c'est terrible c'est une
stigmatisation avis ce pays tout comme
le procès historique concis rabon il est
dans l'actualité
là ce choix là pour nous ce sera un
point de conscience constant et j'ai
pensé aussi aux victimes je me suis dit
le visage de la victime caméraman
inévitablement guettera le moment le
soir on prendra le plan le plus humain
et le plus humain pour elle c'est le
plus déchirant et puis les témoins les
témoins en justice is an ils sont gênés
ils sont rien je passe que bloqué par
certainement alors
la parler savoir qu'on est enregistrée
je parle pas des menaces parce que si
celui truands ils sont là dans le fond
donc c'est pas ça mais savoir que ont
été enregistrées qu'on verra le soir la
justice c'est dans le procès la
recherche de la vérité et la recherche
de la justice elle même je viens d'une
décision juste alors la recherche de la
vérité risque d'être entravée et
risquent d'être bloquées et en
définitive je me suis dit je voi
avantage
oui bien sûr pour la télévision je vois
lanta choix médias je vois surtout les
risques pour la justice elle même et
pour les justiciables
alors oui l'enregistrement historique
celui qu on filmera qu'on l'enregistrera
congard bras qui sera accessible aux
historiens
vingt ans plus tard je proposerai au
parlement qui en débattra vingt ans plus
tard alors là et bien ma foi on pourra
le projeter comme on pourrait projeter
aujourd'hui les procès de la guerre
d'algérie la passion est tombée on
pourra le faire qu'avec autorisation
judiciaire
une dernière question jean louis lejeune
oui dans les affaires criminelles
pourquoi ne ferions pas vers
l'utilisation du sérum de vérité sur les
personnes qui en sont d'accord et sous
le contrôle d'un magistrat bien sûr ne
l'en sûrement pas je mens pas la
recherche l'épreuve en justice elle doit
être marquée d'une exigence de loyauté
et de fiabilité je l'évoqué tout à
l'heure les problèmes des expertises
ce n'est pas pour que nous ayons recours
au sérum de vérité même ordonné par un
magistrat et je ne crois pas qu'ils
accepteraient est en tout cas je
m'exclus de nos lois il ya une dernière
question aux mystiques qui remplit les
journaux et quand vous a pas posé ce
soir parce que pour le monde ose dire
qu'elle rentre pas dans votre
portefeuille
est ce que tu as été consultés sur la
réforme du mode de scrutin souhaitée sur
le fonctionnement du gouvernement je ne
répondrai pas vous voulez savoir mon
opinion sur le mode de scrutin mais
voulait dire qu'on vous demande pas
votre avis la demande de révision ne
donnerait pas ici encore mon avis je le
donnerai au conseil des ministres en
interministériel
nous avons en tant que ja oui et je
dirais même que j'ai une opinion claire
très clair parce que pour moi
quelle doit être la première exige
ans du mode de scrutin semble surprendre
a pas de ma part c'est qu'il soit juste
j'agis pas qui convienne à tel ou tel
parti
il s'agit qu'ils soient justes et juste
ça veut dire exactement oil entre
extensive
attention pas alors non pas un bâti
rectorales parce que à coup sûr on est
en présence d'un scrutin juste quand une
voix d'un français vaut la voix d'un
autre français est en tout cas je suis
assuré qu'on est en présence d'un
scrutin injuste quand la voix d'un
français ne voient pas ne vont pas
autant que la voie ne trouvait alors sur
ce point j'ai eu une petite curiosité
j'ai regardé ce qu'il en était ce qu'il
en était de l'état de justice du scrutin
actuel c'est très simple j'ai journal
officiel réponse est non alors ça donne
ceci on a étudié les 20 circonscriptions
dans lesquels il y a le plus d'électeurs
et ses consultants est quand même là on
arrive à ce paradoxe dans l'essonne pour
élire un député il faut 100 87 mille
citoyens dans les bouches du rhône sens
89 milles mais en lozère il en faut
26000 est à paris 27 mixtes qui veut
dire en clair c'est connu pourquoi les
voies oui mais ça veut dire en clair
ceux ci c'est que un citoyen français
domicilié dans le 8e arrondissement de
paris savoir au fond
elle compte sept fois et demie plus que
celle du citoyen français domicile à
evry j'ai pas cela correspond au prix
des loyers mais c'est un fait on fait
alors complètement j'ai trouvé
d'ailleurs je vous le signale
j'ai trouvé cette remarque voyez j'ai
emporté avec moi de livres seulement oui
seulement et ses deux ouvrages du
général de gaulle alors justement jean
de gaulle le titre clame argument je le
scrutin l'arrondissement je n'avais pas
parce que quand je suis arrivé en 1945
le sco est un arrondissement voulait le
rétablir et j'avais remarqué que les
circonscriptions étaient injustement
découper alors quand même que leurs
marques avant la fin de leur dit vous
avez les circonscriptions les plus
peuplés celle où la voix vole moins 17
sur 20 des députés sont gauche mais les
circonscriptions les moins peuplées
c'est curieux alors là c'est 14 sur 20
c'est des députés de droite va alors
pourtant quelques fois parlé de
magouilles de temps déjà peut-être
common man moi je constate cette
situation et je dis simplement donc il
faut y remédier alors jean legault le
dis là aussi très clairement il dit
évidemment j'aurais pu 45 redécouper les
circonscriptions
mais quelle difficulté est alors vous
imaginez à l'heure actuelle sous les
hurlements le maquillage le charcutage
de ce qu'on a je dis très clairement et
qu'une seule façon pas revenir et c'est
le scrutin proportionnel et là aussi je
veux cette réussite est mon auteur le
général de gaulle toujours le général
toto dans ce domaine puisque les parcs
help our jansana j'entends dire que
l'inde à mourir sur les barricades de la
vème république
alors j'ai interroge la pensée du grand
homme celui que nous respectons là qui
vient dire
permettez moi de dire enfin cet ouvrage
et discours et messages et lis ceci le
général de gaulle permettez moi de dire
qu'un seul système électoral un seul un
seul système électoral a jamais été
établis en france dans l'unique
considération de l'intérêt général
insolent et en unique considération de
l'intérêt général c'est celui qui a été
établie après la libération par
quelqu'un qui n'était candidat bull part
et qui n'avait pas de parti c'est à dire
le général de gaulle lui même
à cet instant-là n'y a jamais eu qu'un
seul moment où un homme a choisi un
scrutin en considération de l'intérêt
général
pour le reste il s'est toujours en
considération l'intérêt des deux parties
donc c'est le général de gaulle
c'est en 1945 il n'est pas éligible il
n'a pas de parti bien qu est-ce qu il
ait choisi vous savez comme moi
le scrutin proportionnel département
c'est tout bon goûter on verra la suite
la semaine prochaine voilà c'était
l'heure de vérité de raymond 2
monsieur robert badinter garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice
prochain rendez vous le 6 mai avec
françois léotard
[Musique]